hello hello
so hello to pikachu
played once before
okay so fun fact
if you want to play an osullivan gambit
against d4
i'll be sure this game but why not
uh then you can start with b5
and then if e4 i'll play knight f6 e5
never mind or if we're not transposing
um
okay at least we have like a reverse
polish type thing
also thank you slow chess
wow
always just giving me a pawn so one of
the points of b5 is
i i was supposed to be preventing c4
but white played c4 anyway
now i want a pawn
okay we'll see how this gamut works for
white
i think i should play e6
just to
keep developing
i guess queen a4 would win back the pawn
but now i have d5
a winning connect four
bishop d6 looks nice
yeah i guess this is a
c4 move is a pikachu gambit
i imagine c4 is like very very rare
i should check the
opening explorer after this game
thank you hooptie subbing for two months
okay yeah this is kind of already
looking really good for black
this pawn is weak
king f2 i have knight g4
oh i am aware of the coca-cola gambit
that's another thing i should add to my
list is just play
play crazy openings
like coca cola gambit
there's a squirrel defense
what else is there
oh there's a medusa
variation
ooh
okay i'll just move my queen away
so my knight's defended by the other
night
and now
yeah
white's pawn structure is
it's like when you
lose half half your teeth
and the dentist is a bit out of reach
oh yeah uh i forgot to think chespa
chespa
for the rate of one
i'm not quite seeing force mate
take the pawn
hitting this defending this
all right there's a lot of ways to
finish things off here
take the bishop king here it's mating
move back
no mercy
it's another game i've had a lot of
games so far this stream
where
like very late into the game i still
have all my pawns
i have potential to have 10 rooks on the
board
all of these pawns are
potential rooks
thank you quail king congrats
i want to play this and allow this where
i lose a pawn it is
i kind of feel bad for pikachu
pikachu is it's one of my favorite
pokemons
oh these pawns are so immaculate the
problem is i can't really wing connect
eight
unless we trade on b2 please play this
move
the hoop is rook h2 we trade on b2 and
then i win connect eight
can i meet with kinect eight
that might be difficult
wow this position is so much fun hey
it's leachate.org
thank you leechest.org for existing
also shout out to lucha.org
if you're just joining this is our
almost two
hour and 53 minutes into
what is probably going to be a 12 hour
stream
uh shout out to leeches.org
for those just joining i'm trying to
remove my pawns
every pawn is a potential rook
i really just want to trade on b2 it
might be hard to make that happen though
i have an idea of how to make it happen
c2 coming
there we go
i i need white to take
ah you took the wrong thing oh i feel so
broken now
okay
i wanted to win connect eight on the
the second rank
the lows
no
i forgot all the queen was turned on
okay i guess i'll make queens in
if i queen this it's stalemate
so
or no it's not stalemate
i feel like ben feingold
go eric rosen america
if i promote if i mistakenly promote it
tonight it's still mate
but uh okay
oh i feel kind of dirty
where's my phone i want to tweet that
i guess i could tweet from the computer
too
okay that was fun thanks to my opponent
oh i
i was up 69 points of material
nice